اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
[موسيقى]
مقتل جندي اسرائيلي في اطلاق نار بمحيط
مستوطنه كلوميم قرب نابلس
الرتبه
والدعم السريع يعلن انضمام قوات من الجيش
لصفوفه والجيش يؤكد قدرته على حسم التمرد
في مدن زمني قصير
تحقيق لصحيفه الواشنطن بوست يظهر ان غرق
قارب المهاجرين في المتوسط كان ماساه يمكن
تجنبها
وشركه ميتا تطلق منصه المنافسه لتويتر
والمشتركون يتجاوزون 14 مليون في غضون
ساعه
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
نبدا من الضفه الغربيه حيث افاد مراسل
العربيه بمقتل جندي اسرائيلي في اطلاق نار
بمحيط مستوطنه كدومي قرب نابلس واوضح
مراسل العربيه ان القوات الاسرائيليه قتلت
منفذ الهجوم بعد ان اصاب مستوطنا بجروح
خطره ايضا
واضافت وسائل اعلام الاسرائيليه ان الهجوم
قربه مستوطنه كادومي استهدف دوريه امن
اسرائيليه
معي من رام الله لمزيد من المتابعه حول
هذا الموضوع مراسل العربيه عبد الحفيظ
جعوان عبد الحفيظ اهلا وسهلا بك اخر
المعلومات المتصله بملابسات هذا الهجوم
وهل يمكن ربطه بالهجوم الاسرائيلي الاخيره
على مخيم جنين
العمليه حدثت قبل نحو نصف الساعه فلسطيني
كان يقود سيارته اقتربا من مدخل مستوطنه
قدميم الواقعه بين نابلس وقلقيليا واطلق
النار بشكل مباشر على حارس امن وهو جندي
حارس امن المستوطنه وبعدها يعني فر من
المكان لاحقته القوات الاسرائيليه ترجل
الشاب من سيارته في مكان قريب باتجاه
مزارع قريبه وحاول الفرار الا انه تم
تصفيته في المكان اثناء محاولتها الفرار
مصادر اسرائيليه تقول ان يعني هي السياره
ذاتها التي ايضا نفذت يوم امس عمليه
باتجاه سياره للشرطه الاسرائيليه في مكان
قريب من مدينه نابلس الان هناك حاله
استنفار كبيره في المستوطنه وهناك خشيه من
ان يكون لديه شركاء الطرق اغلقت في محيط
المكان وعمليات تفتيش واسعه تجري في ذلك
في تلك المنطقه طبعا بالتاكيد يمكن ربط
ذلك وهو مرتبط بشكل اساسي بما يحدث وما
حدث في مدينه جنين بالنسبه للجانب
الاسرائيلي يعني كان يعني هذا يشكل صفعه
كما يصفه الفلسطينيون نتنياهو والحكومه
الاسرائيليه العمليه التي حدثت فيها يعني
شعارها الاساسي كان وقف واحباط عبد الحفيظ
هل تبنى اي فصيل لو سمحت لي هل تبنى اي
فصيل فلسطيني حتى الساعه المسؤوليه واي رد
اسرائيلي متوقع في الساعات المقبله
لا لم يتبنى حتى اللحظه اي فصيل فلسطيني
وبالمناسبه العديد من العمليات اصبحت تتم
بشكل منفرد شبان عاديون لا ينتمون لاي
فصيل فلسطيني من المتوقع طبعا ردود فعل من
الجانب الاسرائيلي اغلاق مناطق عقاب جماعي
وربما اذا تبينت يعني
ظهر ان المنفذ من نابلس كما يعني الاخبار
تحدث حتى هذه اللحظه ربما ذلك يسارع
بعمليه عسكريه كما حدثت في جنين تحدث
باتجاه مدينه نابلس حيث يتواجد فيها ايضا
مجموعه من المسلحين الفلسطينيين الذين
تطاردهم اسرائيل من رام الله مراسل
العربيه عبد الحفيظ جعوان شكرا جزيلا لك
عبد الحفيظ على كل هذه المتابعه
وفي لبنان يسود هدوء حذر منطقتي فرشوبه
ومزرعه حلته في جنوب لبنان بعد قصف
اسرائيلي ردا على قضاء فاطلقت من المنطقه
واوضحت الوكاله اللبنانيه الرسميه للانبا
ان القوات الاسرائيليه اطلقت اكثر من عشره
قذائف وان القصف استهدف منطقه مفتوحه بين
البلدين وعلى المقلب الاخر افاد مراسل
العربيه في فلسطين ان اسرائيل لم تصدر اي
تعليمات
للمستوطنات الشماليه بعد الاحداث الحدوديه
مع لبنان واوضح مراسل العربيه ان القبه
الحديديه لم تكتشف قذيفتي المورتر التي تم
اطلاقهما من جنوب لبنان
[موسيقى]
القصف الاسرائيلي الان
تحت فرشوبه فوق مزرعه حلته
الى هذا المؤتمر الصحفي لامين عام منظمه
النيتو
فانتابع ما يقول
بالطبع بانتظار ما سيقوله يانسيس
في هذا المؤتمر خصوصا يعني وفي البدايه
الموضوع حرب في في اوكرانيا بانتظار اسئله
الصحفيه
مقترحات للرئيس التركي حتى يتخذ القرار
المناسب
[موسيقى]
والمشاركه في الاليه الدائمه وطبعا يمكن
للسويد ان تقدم المزيد طبعا تحت هذه
العناوين لانه يمكن طبعا دائما
تقديم المزيد من التعلم المعلومات وكذلك
التوثيق
التعاون ولكن لا يمكن لي ان افصح او احدد
ما يمكن للسويد ان تقوم به من الان وحتى
انعقاد القمه هذا الامر يعود لسويد وتركيه
اما بالنسبه لبقيه الحلفاء في الرساله
كانت واضحه كل الوضوح من قبل كافه الحلفاء
كلهم باستثناء المجر قاموا بتصديق
وهذا طبعا
تؤمن به هذه الدول باعتبار ذلك مفيدا
للحلفاء وللحلف فيما يخص عضويه السويد وهم
يرون ان هناك قيمه سوف يجنيها الحلف من
خلال انضمام السويد الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
يقدر اجتمعنا اليوم واتفقنا على مذكره
تفاهم في النمسا لاننا نقر بان تركيا
لديها
مواقف مشروعه
وطبعا ليس هناك بين اعضاء الحلف من عانه
من الارهاب كما عانى التركيه وحزب العمال
الكردستاني هو منظمه ارهابيه ثم ادراجه
على قائمه الارهاب ويمكن ان نتعاون معا من
اجل توصل الى قرار كذلك الذي اتخذته محكمه
سويديه اليوم
لمحاربه الارهاب شيء ايجابي
وهذا ما تم تاكيد عليه
على الحلفاء حتى ياخذوا شواغل تركيا
الامنيه على محمل الجد
غرزه
ماذا يعنيه بالنسبه لحلف الاطلسي
استمرار هذه العمليه دون قبول السويد كعض
في الحلف
وما قدم الحلف الى تركيا
وانتم السيد الامين العام سوف تبقون في
المنصب لعام اضافي
اولا مكافحه الارهاب مساله مهمه لكافه
الحلفاء وفي القمه اتخذنا قرارا مهم
تحالف لمحاربه الارهاب لاننا اتفقنا جميعا
على خطط جديده
للدفاع المشترك
قدر من المؤتمر الصحفي ليانسيس كان يتحدث
عن موضوع انضمام السويد الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي وبالطبع المعارضه التركيه لهذا
الانضمام حتى الساعه
ما يزال مصيره قائد مجموعه يسيطر على جزء
كبير من مشهد الاحداث في روسيا جديد
التطورات اعلان رئيس البله الروسيه
الكسندر لوكاشينكو ان بريكوجين غير موجود
على اراضي بلاده بل في مدينه سامبل
الروسيه مشيرا في نفس الوقت الى ان
مقاتليه فاجنر ما يزالون في معسكراتهم
الدائمه
مجموعه روسيه ولديها مقاتلون جيدون حتى
الان هم موجودون في معسكراتهم الدائمه
بالنسبه الى
فهو في سامبا ذهب الى موسكو وربما الى
مكان اخر لكنه ليس على اراضي بيلاروسيا
سنعمل من اجل مصلحه روسيا وسوف نؤدي
واجبنا حتى النهايه وانا متاكد ان بوتين
لا يريد اغتيال بريكوجين او اي شيء من هذا
القبيل
وردا على تصريحات الرئيس البيلاروسي بوجود
بريكوجي في روسيا اكد الكرملين انه لا
يتابع تحركات زعيمر وشدد الكرملين على ان
خروج قائد فاجنر الى بيلاروسيا جزء من
اتفاق انهاء التمرد كما اشار الكرملين الى
ان الاتفاق المبرم مع زعيم فاقنر بوساطه
بيلاروسيا ما يزال ساريا من جهه ثانيه رفض
الكريم للتاكيد عقد لقاء قريب بين الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ونظيره البيلاروسي
الكسندر
عناصر من الامن الروسيه كانوا قداهموا
قصرا لقائد مجموعه فاجنر في مدينه وعثروا
فيه على سبائك ذهبيه ورزما بملايين
الدولارات مع تحف فنيه وترسانه من الاسلحه
اضافه لجوازات سفر المزوره وعثروا في
القصر ايضا على صور غريبه وجدوها في مكتبه
يظهر فيها يفجن بريكوجين بتنكرات مختلفه
اضافه الى صور لرؤوس مقطوعه يعتقد انها قد
تكون لاعدائه الشخصيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك انت حضرت هذا اللقاء مع الرئيس
لوكاشينكو لو تضعنا اولا في اجواءه خصوصا
هذه الحيره والغموض حول مصير ومكان
بريجوجين
والتعارض الواضح بين موقف موسكو وموقف مسك
من مكان بريجوجين على ماذا يدل
مرحبا طالب مساء الخير نعم صحيح ما تقول
هي اكثر من اربع ساعات حوار طويل كان مع
الرئيس البيلاروس الكسندر والذي يعني خصص
الوقت الاكبر منه للحديث عن قضيه فاجنر
وموضوع
ومستقبل هذه المجموعه في الاراضي
طبعا يعني طالب لا يمكن اخفاء حقيقه
الاتحاد بين موسكو وميسي بما يخص كافه
القضايا حتى ان حتى ان الكسندر اليوم توجه
بالحديث بانه قبل دخوله وسيطا خلال تمرد
البروجين على
يتحدث
وقال له يعني ساعتذر منك في حال لم ترضخ
لهذه الامور ولم نتفق واياك لان جيشنا
البيلاروسي جاهز الان وفي حال يعني اضطرت
موسكو واحتاجت اليه
يبدو ان الاتصال انقطع مع عبد الجواد
الرشد لنا عوده اليه في سياق هذه النشره
الان انتقل بكم اعزائي المشاهدين الى
نيويورك لمتابعه وقائع لجلسه مجلس الامن
الدولي حول الملف النووي الايرانيين السمع
الان الى المندوب الروسي نتائج ملموسه ولن
يفضي الى ولن يصب في مصلحتي هذا القرار
ولذلك نحن نرفض هذه الم مشاركه رفضا قاطعا
ونرفض مشاركه اوكرانيا ونحن نؤمن بان
المنطقه التي يتحلى به الاعضاء من المفترض
ان يستعان به من اجل المضي قدما في مناقشه
ملموسه بشان هذا القرار شكرا جزيلا واعطي
الكلمه الان الى الولايات المتحده شكرا
سيدتي الرئيس واعتذر لاخذ الكلمه في هذا
الموعد المبكر ان الولايات المتحده تهيب
بكل الاعضاء
بان يصوتوا لصالح اوكرانيا حتى تتمكن من
التحدث في هذا الاجتماع المنعقد بشان
تنفيذ القرار
الفينواحد وثلاثين ونجد ان روسيا قد
اقلت
بموجباتها بموجب هذا القرار اذ انها تلقت
مسيرات من ايران وذلك بلا موافقه من مجلس
الامن وعلى مدار الاسابيع القليله الماضيه
اين روسيا تستخدم هذه المسيرات في هجماتنا
قتلت المدنيين الاوكرانيين ودمرت الاعمال
والاشغال المدنيه والعموميه الاوكرانيه
هذه مساله حياه او موت بالنسبه للشعب
الاوكراني وانما سنكون معدومي الضمير اذا
ما حرمنا اوكرانيا من فرصه تحدث في هذا
الاجتماع فيما تمر
بالاضرار وبالاضرار المدمره المتمخضه عن
الاخلال بالقرار رقم 2231 اشكر الولايات
المتحده
اولا انا ارفض تماما ما ذهب اليه
المندوب الروسيه في اتهامنا باننا لا نسير
على النهج المعمول بها في رئاسه الامن
ولكننا نعمل بموجب المدى السابعه وبنظر
الى تعليقات التي تفضل بها اعضاء المجلس
اود ان اطرح المقترح مقترح تقديم دعوه
بموجب المدى السابع وثلاثين من النظام
الداخلي المؤقت لمجلس الامن الى ممثل
اوكرانيا للمشاركه في هذا الاجتماع ساطرح
هذا العرض لتصويت
وذلك تحت البند حامل العنوان عدم الانتشار
والان ساطرح هذا العرض او هذا المقترح
للتصويت حالا اولئك المؤيدون لمقترح تقديم
دعوى بموجي المدرسه 37 من النظام الذكري
المؤقت لمجلس الامن الى مندوب اوكرانيا
رجاء ان ترفعوا ايديكم
المعارضون
الممتنعون
نتيجه التصويت كالتالي
احد عشر صوتا مؤيدا صوتان معارضان وصوت
واحد ممتنع
وعليه فان مقترح دعوه مندوب اوكرانيا
اعتمد
اعطي الكلمه الى مندوب الاتحاد الروسي
عفوا
12 12 صوتا اذا قبل ان اعطي الكلمه الى
لتحديد دعوني اصوب هذا الخطا لدينا 12
صوتا مؤيدا وصوتان معارضا واحدا وصوت واحد
عفوا ممتنع الاتحاد الروسيه سيدتي الرئيس
نود ان الفطاع عناياتكم الى انا مشاركه
اوكرانيا في اجتماعي اليوم
فان ايد هذا المقترح اولئك الذين يساندون
الولايات المتحده والولايات المتحده هي
عين السبب وراء عدم انجاز الخطه خطه خطه
العمل المشتركه الشامله وذلك بانسحابهم في
2018 وناسف اننا بيتنا اليوم تحت رحمه
الرئاسه البريطانيه التي انحرفت عن مسار
اداره دفه اعمال المجلس بالطبع من الواضح
ان تمت سؤال جد مهم هل من الممكن ان نتجنب
هذه السابقه في قادم الايام
هل هذا سيؤدي الى اعاده وبات الروح من
جديد في خطط العمل للاسف الشديد من
الرئاسه البريطانيه لم تتعلم من الاخطاء
التي وقعت فيها في رئستها السابقه للمجلس
في عام 2022 الامر الذي يؤدي الى تقويد
ممارسات عمل مجلس الامن
واساءه استخدام رئاسه لدفع قدما بالجند
تخدم مصالحها وذلك حتى تخدم مصالح عملائها
في كييف ولندن واشنطن فهم مستعدون للتضحيه
باي انجاز ممكن حتى بالدبلوماسيه
ويهددون ايضا بالاطاحه باي حل يمكن التوصل
اليه ولذلك ينبغي ان نتعلم من هذا الدرس
اشكر مندوب الاتحاد الروسيه
على ملاحظاته والان اقترح ان نعود من جديد
الى جدول الاعمال ومن ثم فان مقترح دعوه
مندوب اوكرانيا قد اعتمد وعليه فانني ادعو
مندوب المانيا وجمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه
واوكرانيا الى المشاركه في هذا الاجتماع
تقرر ذلك اذا
املا بالماده 39 من النظام الذكري المؤقت
لمجلس الامن ادعو مقدم رائحاته التاليه
اسمائهم الى المشاركه في هذه الجلسه
السيده روزماري دي كارلو وكيل الامين
العام لشؤون السياسيه وشؤون بناء السلام
وصاحب السعاده
الاوروبي لدى الامم المتحده بصفته منسقه
اللجنه المشتركه المعنيه بخطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه تقرر ذلك
يبدا مجلس الامن الان نظر البند الثاني من
جدول الاعمال
اود ان استرعي انتباه اعضاء المجلس الى
الوثائق التاليه
الوثيقه حملت الرمز استشاره 2023
وهو التقرير الخامس عشر للامين العام حول
تنفيذ قرار مجلس الامن رقم 2131
لعام 2015
والوثيقه حمله رمز استشاريتها 2023 شهر
وسبعون عفوا وهو وهي رساله مؤرخه في السبع
والعشرين من يونيو حزيران 2023 من ميسر
المجلس الامن المعني بتنفيذ القرار رقم
الفائتين لعام 2015 موجه الى رئيس مجلس
الامن والوثيقه حمله الرمز اسيا شريطه
2023 شهر 488 وهي رساله مؤرخه في 30 مليون
حزيران 2023 موجهه من ميسر مجلس الامن
المعني بتنفيذ القرار رقم 2131 لعام 2015
وموجهه
موجهه الى رئيس مجلسي الامن
في هذه الجلسه سيستمع المجلس الى احاطات
من السيده الروزماري دي كارلو وصحب
السعاده
السيدر المندوبه الدائمه لمنظر بصفتها
ميسر الامين مجلس الامن عفوا الام معنيه
بتنفيذ القرار رقم 2231 لعام 2015 واعطي
الكلمه الان الى السيده روزما
شكرا سيدتي الرائيس لمنحي هذه الفرصه لكي
اضع مجلس الامن بشان اخر المستجدات فيما
يتعلق بتنخطط العمل الشامله المشتركه
وتنفيذ القرار رقم 2131
الى ابرام هذه الخطه واعتمادها من جانب
المجلس متتماني سنوات كانت نتيجه لمفاوضات
مكثفه من اجل تحقيق اهداف مشتركه تتمحور
حول عدم الانتشار النووي والامني
الاقليميه بطريقه من المفترض ان تعود
بالخير الاقتصادي على الشعب الايراني
وعندما احاطت المجلس علما باثر المستجدات
في اثر مرافض 2022 فان كل المشاركين في
الخطه والولايات المتحده اكدوا من جديد
على ان العوده الى تنفيذ الخطب بطريقه
كامله وناجعه هو السبيل الوحيد
العمليه لحل القضيه النوويه الايرانيه
وبعد ذلك بسته اشهر
توقفت المفاوضات الرميه الى استعاده العمل
بهذه الخطه سيده الرئيسيه هي السبيل
الوحيد من اجل التصدي لقضيه نوويه
الايرانيه بطريقه ناجعه وانهم من الضروري
بمكان بالنسبه لكل الاطراف ان يجددوا هذا
الحوار في اسرع وقت ممكن وان يتوصلوا الى
اتفاق بشان كل القض العالقه وفي هذا
السياق فانا اؤكد من جديد نداء الامين
العام الى الامم المتحده بان ترفع او
تتنازل عن الجزاءات كما هو وارد في الخطه
وكذلك ان
تمدد
المهل الخاصه بالايجار في النفط مع مع
جمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه كذلك اود ان اضم
صوتي الى الامين العام في دعوته ايران ان
تتراجع عن الخطوات التي اتخذتها والتي
تتنافر تماما وتتنافى مع التزاماتها
النوويه بموجب الخطه كذلك فانه من المهم
بالنسبه لايران ان تتصدى لكل الانشغالات
التي اشارت اليها اشار اليها المشاركون في
الخطه وكذلك من جانب دول اعضاء اخرى فيما
يتعلق بالمرفق برقم باء المرفق طي القرار
2131 ونحن نرحب بالتقدم الذي احرز في مارس
من هذا العام
وكاله الدوليه للطاقه اداريه وايران اصدر
بيننا مشترك للاسراع من وتيره
تنفيذي القرار والنظر في كل المسائل
العالقه وفي قرارها الصدر في مايو 2023
فان الوكاله اشارت الى انه اتساقا مع تلك
مع ذلك البيان المشترك فقد ركبت كاميرات
مراقبه في ورش العمل التي تصنع بعض اجزاء
اجهزه الطرد المركزيه الوكاله ايضا اضافت
انه لا يوجد لديها اي اسئله اخرى فيما
يتعلق باليورانيوم عالي التخصيب هذه
الخطوه التي تطلق الصدر على الرغم من كل
ما تقدم
في الحقيقه لا تؤدي الى انجلاء كل ما
يدخلنا من الشكوك فيما يتعلق بعدم قدره
الوكاله من التحقق من تكدس او من مخزون
اليورانيوم المخصب في البلاد بل وان
الوكاله قد اشارت وتقدر ان ايران في الوقت
الراهن قد وصلت
باليورانيوم المخصب الى 20 ضعف ما تسمح به
الخطه هذا يتضمن ايضا
كميات كبيره من اليورانيوم المخصب يصل الى
20% الى 60% والان اود ان اشير الى
التدابير المقيده في المرفق باء والوارده
ايضا في التقرير الخامس عشر الصادر عن
الاميني العام اولا بالنسبه للاحكام
المتعلقه بالجوانب النوويه فلم
قالت قوه الدعم السريع ان مجموعه افراد من
الجيش السوداني انضموا لها من سلاح
المهندسين في ام درمان واضافت قوات الدعم
انها لا ترغب في ان تكون بديلا للقوات
المسلحه وانما ستعمل على بناء جيش مهني
قومي واحد يعبر عن السودان ولا يخضع
لافكار حسبيه حسب بيانهم
وزير الخارجيه السودانيه المكلف عن الصادق
قال من جهته ان تاخر الحسم العسكري في
السودان يعود لوجود افراد من قوات الدعم
داخل المرافق الحكوميه والمنازل مؤكدا
قدره الجيش على الحسم العسكري في مدى قصير
وزير الخارجيه السودانيه اوضح ايضا ان
القوات المسلحه لا ترغب في انتاج سياسه
الارض المحروقه في العاصمه والتي تقضي
بهدم كافه المباني التي يختبئون فيها
وفي اقليم دارفور عبرت قبائل عن استنكارها
للدعوه التي اطلقتها الاداره الاهليه في
الاقليم وطالبت فيها ابناء القبائل بترك
الجيش والانخراض ضمن صفوف الدعم السريع
فيما اعتبرها ناشطون وسياسيون سودانيون
انها دعوه لتاجيج الصراع العرقي غربي
البلاد
لابد لنا ان نحدد موقفنا
الدعوه التي اطلقتها الاداره الاهليه في
دارفور قال عنها نشيطون وسياسيون
السودانيون انها ستؤجج الصراع العرقي غربي
البلاد كونها تطالب ابناء القبائل بترك
الجيش والانخراط ضمن الصفوف الدعم السريع
لكن المعطيات على ارض دارفور لم تسجل اي
استجابه بعد لترك الجيش فضلا عن الرد الذي
جاء على لسان زعماء تلك القبائل بان
الدعوه لا تمثلهم اصلا فما اسباب دعوه
الاداره الاهليه في دارفور يتحدث غالبيه
السكان الاقليم عن انها تاثير التعزيز ثقل
الدعم السريع في دارفور ضد الجيش السوداني
اضافه الى اظهار التفاف القبائل حول الدعم
السريع مقابل التفاف السودانيين حول الجيش
كما انها تعد محاوله لاضعاف قوه الجيش في
دارفور وابراز دور الدعم السريع على انه
المتحكم الاول في الاقليم الى جانب ان حشد
نسبه الاكبر من ولاء القبائل المؤثره في
دارفور لقائد الدعم السريع اعلان الاداره
الاهليه سرعان ما رحبت به قوه الدعم
السريع وارفقته بدعوات اخرى لاتخاذ موقف
مماثل في رفض ما سمته اختطاف مؤسسه الجيش
الاعلان سبقه ايضا انتشار لعدد من المقاطع
المصوره تظهر بيع الاسلحه لقوات ترتدي زي
الدعم السريع
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
بريطانيا تفرض حزمه عقوبات جديده ضد ايران
ووزير الخارجيه يكشف ان ادراج الحرس
الثوري على لائحه الارهاب لا يزال خيارا
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه اعلنت بريطانيا فرضا حزمه عقوبات
جديده تتضمن 13 ادراجا جديدا ضد ايران من
بينها قياده الدفاع السيبراني بالحرس
الثوري الايراني وقال وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه للعربيه ان سياسه العقوبات ضد
ايران مستمره حتى يتغير سلوك النظام
الايراني واضاف ان ادراج الحرس الثوري
الايراني على لائحه الارهاب ما يزال خيارا
قائما مشددا على التزام بريطانيا بمنع
امتلاك ايران لسلاح نووي
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليفر ان
الحكومه البريطانيه ستسعى لوضع حد لعمليات
الاستهداف التي تنفذها طهران ضد المعارضين
للنظام المتواجدين في المملكه المتحده
خلال 18 شهرا الماضي هو 16 محاوله للقتل
او اختطاف اشخاص هنا في المملكه المتحده
من الواضح ان تطهران تحاول اسكات
الانتقادات واسكات الاصوات المعارضه هو ما
نعتبره سلوكا غير مقبول لذا اعلنت اليوم
عن العقوبات التي تعطيني الفرصه وتعطي
الحكومه البريطانيه الفرصه الى الرد على
التصرفات الايرانيه واعلنت ايضا عن ثلاثه
عشره عقوبه اضافيه تحدد الشخصيات تورطت في
القمع الداخلي في ايران والعدوان ضد
المملكه المتحده ولكن اذا تغير السلوك
ايران فلا يكون من الضروري استخدام
العقوبات التي وضعناها
لا تجاه ماساه غرق قارب مقتطف بالمهاجرين
قباله سواحلها نشرت صحيفه الواشنطن بوست
تحقيقا بعنوان كيف غرق مئات المهاجرين تحت
انظار اليونان
التحقيق يشير الى ان غرق القارب في البحر
الابيض المتوسط كان ماساه يمكن تجنبها
السواحل اليونانيه اكد ان الانقاذ المبكر
لم يكن ضروريا لان القارب كان على ما يرام
ويتقدم في مسار وبسرعه ثابته
خفر السواحل اليونانيه دعا ايضا ان قارب
ادريان رفض المساعده بينما افاد خبراء
بالانقاذ البحري ان المسؤولين اليونانيين
استغلوا تلك المؤشرات على ان المساعدات لم
تكن مطلوبه
وفشلوا في التزامهم باطلاق جهود انقاذ
شامله رغم ان التدخل الزامي بغض النظر عن
رغبات بعض الراكبين على متن السفينه
وقد سلطت الصحيفه الضوء عبر احد الخبراء
على غياب الجهات الفاعله التي كانت على
علم بالقضيه ولم تحرك ساكنا عدا عن تجاهل
خفر السواحل اليوناني توفير حلقات وسترات
للنجاه بسرعه وعدم ارسال قوارب صغيره من
سفينه الانقاذ الرئيسيه للاقتراب من
الجانبين لتجنب الدفاع الناس الى جانب
واحد وقلب سفينتهم كما انه كان من الممكن
انشاء قناه اتصال من قارب ادريانا الى
قوارب انقاذ واعطاء التعليمات بلغات
متعدده واجلاء الناس في مجموعات اصغر خلال
رحلات متعدده اذا لزم الامر
فما الذي حدث في التاسع من يونيو تفيد
التقارير ان قارب ادريانا غادر باتجاه
ايطاليا من ميناء بشرق ليبيا وبعد الابحار
لاربعه ايام تم رصد المركب متجها نحو
اليونان
الثامنه صباحا بتوقيت جرينتش خفر السواحل
الايطالي يخطر نظيره اليوناني بان القارب
في منطقه البحث والانقاذ اليونانيه
قرابه العاشره صباحا بتوقيت جرينتش رصدت
طائره مراقبه تابعه لوكاله الحدود وخفر
السواحل الاوروبيه القارب المقتض يتجه
للشمال الشرقي بسرعه بطيئه
وارسلت لقطات في جيول السلطات اليونانيه
والايطاليه
وعلى مدار الساعات التاليه اجرى الركاب
مكالمات استغاثه متكرره عبر خط ساخن غير
ربحي مخصص للاجئين الساعه الثانيه عشره
3:35 بتوقيت جرينتش رصد خفر السواحل
اليوناني القارب عبر مروحيه معلنا ان
القاربه يبحر بمسار وسرعه ثابتتين الساعه
الثالثه واربع وثلاثون دقيقه مساء بتوقيت
جرينتش قال احد الركاب ان القاربه يترنح
وغير مساره
خفر السواحل استعان حينها بناقله نفط
يونانيه للاقتراب من القارب ما ولد امواجا
هددت بانقلابه بحسب شهادات الناجي الساعه
التاسعه واربعين دقيقه مساء بتوقيت جرينتش
وصلت دوريه خفر السواحل في محاوله لسحب
القارب وسط رفض الركاب وفق سجلات قارب
الدوريه
الركاب من جهاتهم ذكروا ان خفر السواحل
اليوناني كان يقودهم نحو ايطاليا
قرابه العاشره واربعين دقيقه مساء بتوقيت
جرينتش تلقى حفر السواحل مكالمه بشان
مشكله في المحرك
لينقلب المركب بعدها بدقائق ويغرق في اعمق
نقطه في البحر المتوسط
من اثنى لمزيد من المتابعه ينضم الي عبر
سكايب الدكتور عبد اللطيف درويش وهو
الاقتصاد واداره الازمات بجامعه
دكتور درويش اهلا وسهلا بك الى نشاط
الخامسه من العربيه هل صدر اولا اي رد فعل
رسمي يوناني على تقرير الوشنطن بوست هذا
والى اي مدى هذا الموضوع يشكل حرجا كبيرا
للسلطات اليونانيه
الحقيقه ان هناك حصار اعلامي لنكون يعني
ذا الدين وواضحين لانه كل الدول الاوروبيه
في حاله هذه الازمات تسعى لتستر ويعتقد
خرجت العديد من
اذا يمكن يعني الفضائح تتعلق باللاجئين
ليس المره الاولى في منطقه الاتحاد
الاوروبي وليس فقط من اليونان وتم التستر
على حتى عدم عرضها على الصعيد الاعلامي
وقد وصل الى اذهاننا من العديد من الذين
شاركوا في المحاكم الاوروبيه او اللجان
الاوروبيه بان هناك بشكل شخصي ومعلومات
شخصيه كان الدول الاوروبيه تورطت في
عمليات اغراق متعمد للعديد من القواعد
ولكن التساؤل هنا لماذا لا تشكل جانب دقيق
مشترك من الدول التي لديها رعايه على
القارب وهذه يعني لماذا هذه الحكومات دول
العالم لا تعير اي اهميه لمواطنين فاحنا
هنا يغرق من دوله واحده 60 او شخص من قريه
واحده من احدى الدول الخمسين لماذا لا
يشاركون في لجان التحقيق لماذا لا ترفع
القضيه الى المحكمه الاوروبيه لحقوق
الانسان لماذا لا يتم
الصور من الاقمار الصناعيه او
منظمات الغير حكوميه لكن هناك اذا كان هذا
التستر اوروبي وحرج اوروبي فهناك ايضا صمت
قاتل من الحكومات التي لا تعتني برعايه بس
دكتور عبد اللطيف اليسا اليس هدف فئات على
هذه الدول الاوروبيه القول ان تمت سياسه
متعمده من قبل هذه السلطات لاغراق هذه
المراكب لكي لا يتكفلوا يعني بكل هؤلاء
اللاجئين يعني
اليس هذا افتئاتا ام لا تعتقد ان هنالك
سياسه متعمده وان كانت غير معلنه بترك
الناس الى مصيرهم وتحصل الماساه
يعني هناك هناك سياسه انتقائيه يريدون
العقول على سبيل المثال المتخصصين
الدارسين ولا يريدون اي لاجئين ومن اي
مكان فبالتالي العمليه الانتقاليه ثانيا
هم ايضا لا يعتبرون الهجره قد تؤثر على
الهويه الاوروبيه او هويه القوميه للدول
الاوروبيه
والثقافه الاوروبيه فهو لا يريدون
اللاجئين وخاصرا بعض الدول فبالتالي نعم
هناك حدثت عمليه اغراء ما تعمل يعني لا
ننسى ان الان الاحزاب الفاشيه والنازيه هي
تعتبر في بعض الدول الحزب الثاني كما
فرنسا او الحزب الثالث في العديد من الدول
الاوروبي هناك الصعود
للاحزاب هذه والاحزاب دائما هذه تتوغل
وتنشق في الاجهزه العسكريه والاجهزه
البوليسيه والسياديه فبالتالي حتى ان لم
يكن هناك تورط رسمي فقد يكون هناك طوارئ
بشكل فردي
بمزاجيه فرديه من الذي يضمن سلوك جندي او
مجند او شرطي في عمر 19 عاما 22 عاما في
هذه الحاله فبالتالي يجب ان يكون هناك
تحقيق حسب لكن يجب ان عبد اللطيف يعني
هنالك جمعيات حقوق انسان كثيره هنالك
احزاب معارضه
للحكومه طيب الم يطالب هؤلاء بفتح تحقيق
جنائي فيما جرى ام لا عندما ياتي الامر
الى موضوع اللاجئين الكل يصطف وراء موقف
الحكومه
هناك بعض الاحزاب اليساريه على سبيل
المثال يعني نوعت الى الموضوع وحتى حزب
المعارض نوه الى الموضوع ولكن تم التهجم
عليهم بشكل الاعلام على انهم يساعدون
توريط الدوله في قضايا ليست صحيحه وانهم
يسيئون الى الاجهزه السياديه واخلاقيات
ولكن المساله انا لا اقول انا اليونان قد
المتعمد او غير متعمده الذي قد يثبت ذلك
لجان التحقيق التي يجب ان تكون ليس فقط في
اليونان والاخرى الحقيقه هذا القارب كانت
تعلم به ايطاليا وتعلم به اليونان وتعلم
به مالطا ولكن كل دوله كانت تتمنى ان تجرف
الامواج هذا الخارج باتجاه الدوله دوله
اخرى يعني وتم الحديث في العديد من
المناسبات ان بعض خفر السوائل هذه الدول
كان يواجه هؤلاء اللاجئين او غيرهم باتجاه
المياه الاقليميه لدول اخرى اوروبيه لانه
الكل يريد ان يتنصف من المسؤوليه من اثنا
عبر سكايب الدكتور عبد اللطيف درويش
استاذه الاقتصاد واداره الازمات بجامعه
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
انتهاء عمليه فصل التوام السيامي السوري
احسان وبسام بمدينه الملك عبد الله الطبيه
في الرياض
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه وصل عدد المشتركين في تطبيق فرجس
بعد ساعات من اطلاقه الى نحو 14 مليون
وكانت شركه فيسبوك متى قد اطلقت التطبيق
وهو منصه جديده منافسه لتويتر ما يشكل
اكبر تهديد حتى الان للمنصه التي يملكها
ايلون ماسك
وكتب مارك زوكربيرج الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
ميتا ومؤسس فيسبوك في اول منشور له على
المنصه الوليده
لننطلق ومرحبا بكم في
[موسيقى]
انتهت اليوم عمليه فصل التوم السيامي
السوري بسام واحسان والتي جرت في الرياض
وذلك انفاذا لتوجيهات العهد السعودي الملك
سلمان ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
واوضح رئيس الفريق الطبي والجراحي الدكتور
عبدالله الربيعي ان العمليه استغرقت قرابه
تسع ساعات وتمر بخمس مراحل بمشاركه 26
عضوا من الاستشاريين والاخصائيين بالاضافه
الى الكوادر الفنيه والتمريضيه المسانده
وبعد نجاع عمليه فصل التوام السيامي
السوري بسام واحسان اكد رئيس الفريق الطبي
لفصل التوام الدكتور عبد الله ربيعه اكد
ان هناك العديد من التحديات التي واجهت
الاطباء خلال اجراء العمليه ما يميز هذه
العمليه هاني هو وجود في الواقع التحدي
الكبير لان التوام احسان متطفل على اخي
بسام ويشكل خطرا عليه فلولا سمح الله
صارت مشكله في القلب لدى احسان سوف تنعكس
على اخيه بسام لذلك عندما بدات عمليه
الفصل في المرحله الثالثه كان هنالك
شرايين مشتركه وهذه الشرايين قد تنقل
السموم من احسان الى اخيه وقد تشكل خطر
لذلك كان امامنا تحدي ان ننهي هذه المرحله
بسرعه حتى لا نواجه خطر على التوام
المكتمل والذي هو بسام
الحمد لله رب العالمين الله يجزيكم الخير
والله يبارك فيكم وما حدا قصر والحمد لله
رب العالمين فرح الف حمد وشكر لرب
العالمين الله منا علينا يعني في فصل
الاطفال والله يجزيهم الخير قادر الطبيه
بقياده الدكتور عبد الله الدكتور محمد
مشان الله يحفظهن ويكرمهم وبنشكر سمو
الملك سلمان جزيره الشكر ونشكر ولي العهد
محمد على المساعده وعلى الخدمه الانسانيه
اللي قدم لنا اياها بوصول لهون
وعدت ام بي سي الشيخ وليد ال ابراهيم كشف
ان قناه العربيه حلت في المرتبه الاولى
على مستوى الوطن العربي من حيث نسبه
المشاهده اليوم اليوم العربيه
واصله للشعوب اكثر من اي قناه عربيه ثانيه
اليوم كيف نسب المشاهده نسب مشاهده
العربيه اليوم في العالم العربي اكبر من
اي قناه ثانيه يعني العربيه والحدث حتى
الحدث
خامسا انتهت اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات